the autoionization of water refers to
the reaction of water molecules to form
two ions the hydronium ion which is h3o
plus and the hydroxide ion which is oh
minus
water can function as an acid or base
and in this reaction one water molecule
functions as a bronsted-lowry acid and
donates a proton
and another water molecule functions as
a bronsted-lowry base
and accepts a proton in the reaction the
base takes an
h plus ion from the acid and these two
electrons are left behind
on this oxygen adding an h plus to h2o
gives the hydronium ion h3o plus
and taking away an h plus from h2o gives
the hydroxide ion o h minus
we can write an equilibrium constant
expression for this reaction
so we would write the equilibrium
constant k is equal to
we would start with our products we'd
have the concentration of hydronium ions
and since we have a coefficient of one
in front of hydronium and the balanced
equation it'd be the concentration of
hydronium ions raised to the first power
times the concentration of hydroxide
ions
and once again there's a coefficient of
one the balanced equation so it's the
concentration of hydroxide ions raised
to the first power
for the reactants liquid water is left
out of the equilibrium constant
expression
normally we would write k c where the c
stands for concentration for the
equilibrium constant since we're dealing
with concentrations
however this is a special equilibrium
constant expression for the
autoionization of water so instead of
writing kc
we're going to write kw where w stands
for water
kw is equal to 1.0 times 10 to the
negative 14th at 25 degrees celsius
and with such a low value for kw so this
value is much less than one
that tells us at equilibrium we have an
extremely small concentration of
hydronium
and hydroxide ions so mostly we have
h2o molecules at equilibrium
let's go ahead and solve for the
concentration of hydronium ions and
hydroxide ions
at equilibrium in the balanced equation
there's a coefficient of one in front of
both hydronium
and hydroxide therefore at equilibrium
these two concentrations
are equal since we don't know what those
concentrations
are we're going to represent it by
writing in here x
so this would be x times x is equal to
1.0 times 10 to the negative 14.
so we would have x squared is equal to
1.0
times 10 to the negative 14. and taking
the square root of both sides
we would find that x is equal to 1.0
times 10 to the negative seventh
therefore if we had a sample of pure
water at 25 degrees
celsius the concentration of hydronium
ions and the concentration of hydroxide
ions
would be equal to 1.0 times 10 to the
negative seventh
instead of using two water molecules to
show the autoionization of water
it's also possible to show it using only
one water molecule
so h2o could break up to form h plus
and o h minus so h plus which is the
hydrogen ion
is sometimes used interchangeably with
h3o plus which is the hydronium ion
we've just seen that pure water has the
concentration of hydronium ions equal to
the concentration of hydroxide ions
therefore pure water is a neutral
substance
and for any aqueous solution where the
concentration of hydronium ion is equal
to the concentration of hydroxide ion
we would classify that as a neutral
solution
if an aqueous solution has a
concentration of hydronium ions that's
greater than the concentration of
hydroxide ions
we would classify the solution as an
acidic solution
and if an aqueous solution has a
concentration of hydronium ions that's
less than the concentration of hydroxide
ions
or you could say the concentration of
hydroxide ions is greater than that of
hydronium
the solution would be considered a basic
solution
and the equation that we've already
talked about the concentration of
hydronium ions times the concentration
of hydroxide ions
is equal to kw which which is equal to
1.0 times 10 to the negative 14 at 25
degrees celsius
this equation is true if you're dealing
with an acidic solution
a neutral solution or a basic solution
and i'll call this equation the kw
equation from now on
let's say we have an aqueous solution
and the concentration of hydronium ions
in solution is equal to 4.0 times 10 to
the negative 6 molar
at 25 degrees celsius and our goal is to
calculate the concentration of hydroxide
ions
in this solution at 25 degrees celsius
to solve for the concentration of
hydroxide ion we can use
our kw equation so we need to plug in
for the concentration of hydronium ion
so that gives us 4.0 times 10 to the
negative
six times the concentration of hydroxide
ion which we'll just go ahead and make
x here and all that's equal to kw which
is equal to 1.0
times 10 to the negative 14. solving for
x
we find that x is equal to 2.5
times 10 to the negative 9.
and since x is equal to the
concentration of hydroxide ion
the concentration of hydroxide ion is
equal to 2.5 times 10 to the negative
ninth molar for this aqueous solution
the concentration of hydronium ion
is greater than the concentration of
hydroxide ion
therefore this is an acidic solution so
let me go ahead and write that in here
this is an acidic
solution an equilibrium constant is only
constant at a specific temperature
for example at 25 degrees celsius kw
is equal to 1.0 times 10 to the negative
14.
but if you change the temperature you
change the value for kw
at 50 degrees celsius kw is equal to 5.5
times 10 to the negative 14th
so an increase in temperature from 25
degrees celsius to 50 degrees celsius
causes an increase in the value for kw
so increase in temperature causes an
increase in
kw and we can use le chatelier's
principle to predict if the
autoionization of water is an
endothermic reaction
or an exothermic reaction an increase in
kw means an increased concentration of
hydronium ion and hydroxide ion at
equilibrium
therefore the net reaction must have
gone to the right
to increase the amount of our products
and if we treat heat as a reactant
and we increase the temperature it's as
if we've increased the amount of one of
our reactants
therefore according to le chatelier's
principle the net reaction is going to
shift to the right
to make more of the product since that's
what we observe by increasing the value
for kw
we know that the autoionization of water
is an endothermic
reaction if we had put heat on the
product side and treated this like an
exothermic reaction
we would have gotten a shift in the
wrong direction we've got to shift back
to the left so we know it's not
exothermic
finally let's calculate the
concentration of hydronium ions and
hydroxide ions
in a sample of pure water at 50 degrees
celsius we can still use the kw equation
so kw
is equal to the concentration of
hydronium ions times the concentration
of hydroxide ions
however since the temperature is now 50
degrees celsius
we can't use 1.0 times 10 to the
negative 14
because that's the kw at 25 degrees
celsius we need to use the kw at 50
degrees celsius which is 5.5 times 10 to
the negative 14th
for the autoionization of water the mole
ratio of hydronium ion to hydroxide ion
is one to one
therefore the concentration of hydronium
ion is equal to the concentration of
hydroxide ion
so when we plug in for hydronium if you
say that concentration is
x and the concentration of hydroxide
would also be x so we have x
times x is equal to kw which is equal to
5.5 times 10 to the negative 14.
so x squared is equal to 5.5 times 10 to
the negative
14th and to solve for x we simply take
the square root of both sides
so x is equal to 2.3
times 10 to the negative seventh so the
concentration of hydronium ions is equal
to the concentration of hydroxide ions
which is 2.3 times 10 to the negative
seventh molar
notice that this is a higher
concentration than we got at 25 degrees
celsius which makes sense because the
value for kw has increased
however since the concentration of
hydronium is still
equal to the concentration of hydroxide
ions
pure water is still neutral